so I ran that wonderful beacon of
justice and freedom and fairness in the
world that is putting out so much
positivity and so many good things and
is wonderful to women and gays and all
that good stuff they're not happy with
America's well the trayvon martin george
zimmerman verdict and the Iranian
Foreign Ministry has released a
statement on the verdict the acquittal
of the murderer of the teenage
african-american once again clearly
demonstrated the unwritten but systemic
racial discrimination against racial
religious and ethnic minorities in the
u.s. Society the court ruling has also
seriously put under question the
fairness of the judicial process in the
United States now many Americans
actually would agree with that and I
agree with part of it of course but it's
a little odd that Iran where literally
they stone women to death you can be put
to death for being gay I mean I don't
have to go on and on the list of human
rights violations over there but they're
doing this is this just all you know
over-the-top bravado because they want
to do anything to make the us look bad
or divert attention from the nuclear
situation this is the Don said as you
said many Americans would agree with
that yeah I'm one of them but the thing
is is because it comes from this type of
source then it's very easy to write off
and then for the people who do agree
with it or don't want things to change I
don't want a certain level of fairness
to rise in our country's judicial
process yeah they'll say well you know
where that came from so now you agree
with Iran who has all of these human
rights violations and intimidation
factors for opponents of their
government yeah that's a great point so
the people that are backing Zimmerman
you're actually strengthening is now
right yeah that's what they do they just
clump us together but I think you really
have to pay attention to the statement
itself and they talked about the
unwritten aspect of racial now see the
thing is in Iran it's written yeah it's
an the laws so what they're saying is
actually really they they have a point
they have a beef like if you're gonna be
this prejudice and you're going to have
this kind of a culture be upfront about
it just like we are right because they
are and the fairness in their country
there's not a lot of fairness in their
country we claim fairness here so I
think they have a point in it
ance because they're saying walk your
walk you know walk your talk if you're
gonna talk a certain way then really
live that but clearly your laws do not
live up to these things you talk about
in your country right is that legit
though in any way or is it or well it's
just a legit right it's just absurd
began but I was like not to say it
doesn't have a degree of truth in the
essence of yes and I don't know if that
was a gawky their point but when you
look at the semantics of that statement
you're like they do use specific words
you know written you know unwritten I
mean this is these are things to think
about yeah it is highlighted by when
people want to bring up the issue i want
to change something that the way we do
things in the country it's just quiet
you know that was a jury you cannot
disparage the decisions of the jury
their citizens why can't I disparage the
city's the decisions that citizens made
especially after I hear that one of them
was completely off-kilter and thinking
connecting with one particular outside
of this case and then completely
disconnected with the other you're
talking about be fair he says yes I mean
it's an indication of what our society
is in discussion so that you can once
you can you I can't we point that out
yeah do you think we're just reaping
what we sow here in America now because
we tell everybody what to do all the
time so even though it's absurd for us
to take a directive on morals from Iran
I mean this is what we push across
everywhere so we're just getting it back
right absolutely and everyone's got an
opinion nowadays so Iran's got an
opinion also but you know I was thinking
this the other day about you know how
everyone hates jury duty in this country
we hate it we do everything you can to
get out of it right and then a decision
like this comes down and we get pissed
about it well if we really want our
justice system to change we need a
citizens to take responsibility and we
need to start understanding that being a
member of a jury is our responsibility
and a great privilege in this country
yes that we actually have eight we do
have a jury system and most of the time
it works right because 12 people this
was only six people in the Zimmerman
thing but 12 people come together and
work it out and and try to interpret the
law the best we can and I'm just kind of
sick and tired of people pissin and
moanin about juries and you know right
what happens to you could clearly be
ours cuz it could be like how it is in
Iraq where they're just judges and they
just do it
they want and we have those kind of any
others there's two people in the country
who would do jury duty every week my
parents there the jury summons comes and
I feels they're excited yeah I mean they
watch the judge shows and they may watch
the judge to point dramas and they grew
up in a time when it was it as may be as
explicit as Iran's laws are against
certain minorities yes and like all we
do I want to be on this joy yet could
give me the case right that's really
funny you know I was called in for jury
duty a couple months ago and i was
living in new york still and the entire
time I kept thinking I wanted to get out
of it naturally and the entire because
I'm not as good of a citizen as you want
us all to be but I kept in the entire
time could i plead comedian to them
because i can't sit there and do this
the way regular people you're my
everything about me is going to try to
make fun of the system and i'm gonna use
this in a bit you can have that truth
getting out there and I thought but
needless to say i didn't get picked no